what you guys first started talking
about the character how far along were
you in writing was it completely
finished or did you have conversations
that shape the way that that the
character was gonna come together the
script was completely finished and when
Jake was available and suddenly we were
really wanted Jake to play the part I
flew to Atlanta and he was doing
prisoners and we sat down to dinner and
the first question he asked me was how
do you see the film and I said I see it
as a success story and he's just burst
out laughing he said that's exactly the
way I see it it takes all moral judgment
off the character which allows the
character to flourish to become a human
being rather than a reductive label of a
sociopath or whatever read every
diagnostic tool you wanted to apply to
the character and it's just I think as a
writer it liberated me writing it and I
know as an actor when I said that I
think Jake realized yes that that's
going to allow me people sometimes asked
who was surprised with what he did with
the darkness of the character I'm always
continually surprised by the inner
landscape of the character that he
discovered the human landscape that that
he discovered go ahead I mean and I
would just say that it I just stuck
totally to the word I mean it was a
word-for-word period for period there
are not many commas because there was
very little hesitation when Lou has
direction or directive he continues
through it almost like a 50 caliber
machine gun you know I mean that's how I
think about that in the Cobb Anita scene
is that I've been equipped with this
like 50 caliber machine gun of dialogue
and she has a spoon and it is a
testament to her as an actor and you
know the irony of that scene is that she
has her hand on my leg the entire scene
under the table she did what we're doing
yeah so I mean she was trying in every
way she could if she was going down but
she really she really ya know well
that's our backstory but that that was
really you know that was really that
that is a testament to her choices
because I expected to come in there and
win not only as the character but also
as the actor and the way knowing I had
all that stuff that he had given me and
she threw me off at every turn
you know and I that was it was the fun
part of doing the scene you know not
only was it brilliantly written and we
kind of knew where we were going and it
was headed to this great place we knew
storytelling wise but as actors you know
she just kept throwing me off and you
know she would wink there were so many
things that did to me on my coverage and
then weirdly being the married to the
writer director was also encouraging me
when I wouldn't get it they're married
yeah so I I think the only argument dan
and I had a disagreement is that he
really saw it Nina as more of a victim
and I said to him no no I'm in control
so I so so that's not true I wasn't
completely in control I did make my own
decisions however I didn't think of
myself completely as a victim because if
he wasn't gonna bring me the goods then
I wasn't gonna give him whatever it was
we were doing tell us what they do
behind closed doors security well there
be but that's a clear choice that you
make and in the screenplay or do you
actually have that you reference
something that you I mean you have dealt
with so little exposition of this story
I'm wondering Jess you're talking with
your writer director there's very little
exposition is that something that you
guys said from the get-go was really
important well obviously the script
began that way but there there is there
there were more clues actually and there
were scenes with a few more clues as to
who Lew was is a little bit of his
backstory and particularly in the
apartment production design wise there
were more there were just more clues but
um I think that's what makes him this
enigma and and part of the power of the
story is that he is because I feel like
he's a bit of a walking metaphor and
that was what we talked about a lot that
he's the creation he's our creation he's
a modern day creation and he couldn't
really exist any other time and he he
for me specifically had a backstory but
I don't think it was necessary for the
audience and I think actually it would
only have hurt it had we known really
where he came from because he really
comes from our own minds he talked when
our first one of her first discussions
was about the topography of Los Angeles
and how
you know Lu was an animal you know one
of those animals that came down at night
from the mountains you know the mountain
ranges and then down to the metropolis
and when his he starts speaking about
him in this primal way I just really
started getting me thinking and there
were a number of references in the
script to coyotes you know and anybody
who's obviously lived in you know the
southern part of Los Angeles or you know
of California really knows coyotes and
you know your interaction with them and
growing up here you know many many times
I was um I've crossed paths with the
coyote and they looked at me that very
much the way I thought Lou would look at
most of his prey
you know and so we just decided you know
Lou is a coyote you know there was an
evolution of him at the camera you know
at first it was almost like a puppy you
know and then inevitably like he became
really agile with it he started adding
different things to it and we that we
spent with Robert ELLs but we went with
these two brothers who are happened to
be real streamers real night crawlers
here in LA and we copied their cameras
and we copied of everything they had as
the Lou became agile and a real
professional but the way he moved was
very important to me while he was
carrying that camera and really trying
to move like a coyote and then maybe
look like him you know look like Audi
and be starving really like they are
what comes to when I watched the film is
that hunger the unspoken hunger there's
just that he's capable of eating a
person or an idea or a watch or anything
it's just there's this he will suck
things into him and and to me you could
look at the physical transformation and
say well that's that's that's the big
benefit of losing the weight but to me
the in addition to that was was this
undefined quality that I see in every
frame did that actually did affect you
mentally I mean did you actually find
yourself changing that way yes I mean
there's a chemical change when you work
nights anyway we all know that but then
also when you're not eating in your
working nights you know you can times
out by four you know but I yeah I think
that that that that did nothing but you
know when I read the word at first you
know the word was a real guide for me
and I say that because it you know this
was loose Bible this script you know the
very one of the very first lines he says
is I was under the opinion that this was
a detour to go and and that was for me
the biggest directive of who he was he
he he just changed things to his own
opinion and he had to move forward that
way and he would he'd eat anything in
his path there's other little flourishes
that he did that were surprised that
were wonderful surprised the day he put
his hair up in the bun I was like oh my
god that's totally wild I'm gonna wear a
little scrunchie on my on my wrist
through the whole movie I'm like oh man
that's just it all makes sense now but
there was a time that it was it was wow
this is just wild we would call that
going ninja I would say do you want do
I'm gonna go ninja in the scene I want
to ask two producers at the end about
shooting in Los Angeles you are one at
the very end of I think the production
pre-production you got a California
incentive we considered briefly you
apply for the lottery July first and you
find out months later so we had to start
prepping the movie and start spending
money before we knew whether or not we
would be a recipient and it was but we
decided that it was a gamble worth
taking because it was a beg borrow steal
production and we couldn't have gone to
Shreveport I made the movie we couldn't
go into al-bakr we could we yeah we were
we were but we had to say we we could do
it maybe I mean the reason that the
movie because we made this movie for so
little money I mean I were supposed to
say under ten but we're well under ten
and we you know and it should cost it
should really cost eighteen or something
like that and the reason that it you
know the reason that it worked out
wasn't just the lottery it's the fact
also of and everybody in this room kind
of knows how this works I mean we were
making a movie from October to December
people could stay home and stay home for
Christmas before they took their big
money job someplace else so we just
loaded on all these just top top people
you know we started the king so we have
as Ferrari
Ferrari engine lithographer Robert
Ellsworth we shall but people could you
know you could have Andy Roland's be
your camera operator you could have all
the everybody we had they could stay at
home and say honey I'm gonna stay home
for Christmas you know and I'll be home
for Christmas and I won't make any money
won't be here and and that's why the
movie is what it is and it's it's
shooting in LA and nobody else was here
we I didn't really try to play any moral
judgment to local television news I feel
I feel it's it's a it's a it's it's a
very complicated system that's in place
they're reacting to to to a very real
economic need which is that it turns out
that people like to watch these images
and it's like saying like if you if
should we be anger to people to make
fast food well it turns out we like fast
food and I think I think the difference
between fast food and and what the local
television news does is that fast food
comes with how many calories under each
meal and so you can actually see how
dangerous it's for you first is what you
watch on local television news and you
might be aware that they're doing this
but I don't think anybody's fully aware
of perhaps with what the toll is for our
society in terms of us all walking
around in some vague state of fear all
the time and being afraid of anybody who
shows up in our neighborhood we don't
know or or politicians who point to the
crime stories on television as a way of
making policy if the movie succeeds the
way you intended it to what do you hope
people are thinking about or talking
about after they've seen the film I hope
that people look at the film and and
come away with thinking that the problem
in this story is not Lou although Lou is
a problem for some people in the story
it's it's it's the problem is the
society that created him and rewards him
and I firmly believe in Jake and I'd
conversations about this I firmly
believe in the writing of it that if you
came back in ten years Lou would be
running a major multinational
corporation I mean that all seriousness
I don't really I think all the elements
that or qualities that make Lou survive
at nighttime in Los Angeles driving on
these crime scenes would serve an
extraordinarily well in the boardroom
and I think what Lou does is small
potatoes compared to CEOs who take over
a company and and and break it up into
aggregate parts and put 50,000 people
out of work and then build a 500 foot
yacht and wind up on the cover of
Businessweek magazine for their acumen
and I mean that seriously I feel I feel
that we live in a world
that's increasingly leaning that way and
and perhaps to look around you and and
try to say you know what
who do I know like that what part of me
is like that jumps the level of
self-awareness you know hopefully